et puis une nomination ce matin ce
mercredi matin en conseil des ministres
le directeur de la dgse la direction
générale de la sécurité intérieure a été
nommé préfet des yvelines
erard corbin de mangoux à 60 ans il
avait été désigné par nicolas sarkozy
pour digérer diriger la dgse il ya
quatre ans michel jau de son côté accède
au grade de préfet de région il rejoint
la haute vienne
1 michel zoah les prix et le poste de
préfet des yvelines après avoir dirigé
le cabinet de patrick devedjian au
ministère chargé de la mise en oeuvre du
plan de relance
je vous retrouve jeudi mêmes horaires
pour une nouveau tour de l'actualité
locale un point complet excellente
soirée à demain jeudi